- Wednesday morning, rainy
London, seems appropriate.
(rhythmic music)
Just had a great breakfast
with Eric Fulwiler,
who runs London, the
Intermedia, that was his back.
It's good to see you D-Rock,
we haven't been traveling
together that much.
It's all going well, vlog,
just kind of trucking
along, I think, I think--
- Hi Gary.
- Hello! How are you?
- Wow, what are you doing here?
Nice to meet you!
- Nice to meet you.
- Do you mind if I take a selfie?
- Yeah real quick, real quick.
- Okay, sorry.
Are you in London for long, or?
- I have an office here and
we're just going to a meeting.
- Oh my God, okay.
- Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
We're not going to, I'm
not going to let it--
- Okay, I don't know if it's the water.
- We're just going to use Instagram.
(camera shutter slicking)
Boom.
- Oh my God, amazing, thank you so much!
- Awesome, take care.
- Bye!
- So, um, just a,
that's a funny segue based
on what just happened,
but it's so interesting to me that like
96% of my time
is being the CEO and Chairman of VaynerX
and the CEO of Intermedia.
We're gonna have to,
actually this is a
challenge I'm putting to us.
We need to do a lot more,
why don't we do a vlog of like b-roll,
'cause we can't show anything,
a lot of sensitive information.
Why don't we do an episode where
we use the entire Monday
to Monday playlist.
- [Cameraman] Yep.
- But show every meeting,
and maybe write at the
bottom a little context
of the meeting, like
account meet, you know?
- [Cameraman] Yeah, yeah.
- Anyway, that's what's up, vlog.
Busy as fuck, building a machine.
We have a new office in London.
I'm excited about it.
That's what's up.
- Hello.
- [Cameraman] How you doing?
- I've been well, how are you?
- [Cameraman] Fantastic.
- I'm super fired-up to
be in London right now.
♪ I've been told when a boy kiss a girl ♪
♪ Take a trip around the world ♪
(upbeat guitar music)
- Um, we switched things up,
trips to London recently,
which has been, I think,
beneficial for Eric and the team.
Truthfully what we did
was just fly in on like a late flight,
and we get in in the morning,
we kind of beat off a red-eye,
and then only get like a quarter of a day,
and then a full day and fly home.
Our new strategy is kind
of fly out in the morning,
get in at 8 p.m. local,
which is mid-afternoon back in the U.S.,
do two hours of calls, hit the sack,
and then just rip through two full days.
We're also switching it up a little bit
trying to get more into the media here,
just kind of getting
ingrained in the culture.
So today is just straight,
full day of some new business
meetings, interstitial press,
and then tomorrow kind of
ramping it up a little bit
and we've got a fun pod session set up
for tomorrow afternoon with
some soccer players,
some football players.
- [Cameraman] Everyone on the 40.
We have the 40 so a lot of
Vayner folks that are here,
Ben Ruby, Nicholson, we miss you Claud.
Followed by the K Sports event at night,
which is going to be kind of fun because
the first two pop-ups in Toronto and L.A.
were really like time-constraint,
90 minutes, two hours,
so we had to just rip through,
rip through, rip through.
This one's got a little more time
and so it's been, what was it,
a year ago that we did the last meet-up?
Two years ago?
Which was like a big moment, I think,
for everyone, was like oh, shit.
And so tomorrow night, we're
kind of just leaving it open,
and hopefully just get a
lot of the public people
to come through and catch
the vibe and should be good.
The new office is super phat.
(cameraman speaking quietly)
They have a coffee machine,
but I went out and bought coffee anyway,
'cause I like it, I'm
a big coffee shop guy.
- [Cameraman] Oh, oh, hold on.
- You got fucked up?
(guitar music)
Sent him on the road, to a meeting.
Eric likes logistics, so we're good to go.
And Alex is texting me at 4
a.m. back in New York right now.
She's on her game, we're
rocking and rolling.
(rock music)
- Amazing, I'm fired up,
Reece has got me fired,
I mean, this sweatshirt is like--
- Burning!
- I mean, I can't even.
- London is ready, man.
- By the way, for all
of you that don't know,
that's the logo I grew up with.
- Oh, really, the old-school one?
- Yeah, that's, well, they
have the old-school one now.
There was an old-school one,
they switched to that in the early 80s.
- Yeah.
- Uh, late 70s
- And it went back.
- It went back to the original,
but that's like my logo.
- I'm mad.
- That's my logo.
- This is really crazy, I
was just saying to Gary,
we've got like six, seven
people upstairs who,
are all my boys and this
guy's changed their lives
and make them start doing
stuff like vlogging.
It's super crazy.
- I can't wait to see them.
- It's nice, 'cause you don't
come to London that much.
- No.
- The vibe and the energy, is really like,
do you know what I mean,
it's 'cause we don't get to see you,
it's just on the screen.
- I get it, I mean, tomorrow
night's gonna be crazy.
(cheering)
- Gary V!
- Legend.
- What's up man, how are you?
Such a pleasure.
Hey man, how are you?
- Very well man, you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you man.
- How are you?
- Take care.
- Real pleasure.
- Antony, nice to meet you.
- Antony, how are you?
Good to see you.
- How's it going, I'm Alex.
- Alex, how are you man?
- Pleasure.
- You well?
- Yeah, very well man.
- Good.
- Ashra.
- Ashra, what's up man?
- Nothing, you, man?
- Real pleasure.
How are you?
- Pharon.
- Pharon, such a pleasure,
how are you guys?
- Good, when we got to London
when it actually got warm
and now it's snowing.
- I know, I brought that, New
York's at 12 inches right now
I'm feeling good about myself.
- [Interviewer] Three tips
to get happy, stay happy,
and I guess financially secure,
but that goes into the happiness as well.
- Well, I don't know about that.
Like I really think the
money and happiness thing
is a very big confusion.
Most of my richest friends are miserable,
and some of my poorest
friends are super happy,
so that's just one point.
But let's break it down, couple things.
The biggest reason people
are unhappy right now
is 'cause they value
somebody else's opinion
more than they value their own.
That is the number-one blanket statement
that I've got for everybody.
Your mother's point of view on you,
your wife's point of view on you,
your boyfriend's point of view,
your homie's point of view.
Like, the reason I'm super happy is
nobody can tell me nothing.
My wife, mom and daughter can
walk into my room right now,
tell me I'm a piece of crap,
and I would be 100% unfazed.
That is some gangster emotional structure.
And that's why I can never lose.
I know who I am and I'm just unfazed.
So if my mom, daughter
and wife could come in
and tell me I'm a piece
of crap and I'm cool,
what do you think that troll on Instagram
that says I suck does?
Nothing.
So, you need to figure out the following:
it is very likely that
either your mom or dad
screwed you up, they made you insecure,
they didn't love you enough,
they told you you weren't good
because they weren't good,
and misery loves company.
Once you face that demon,
once you cut out negativity
and the people that hold you down,
and you surround yourself with positivity,
and don't confuse delusion,
don't watch my videos
and rah-rah up and you
don't put any work in,
nothing good's going to happen.
You're just going to watch my videos.
So don't get it confused,
but life is basic.
You're either on the optimism team
or you're on the pessimism team,
you're either on the offense
or you're on the defense.
The reason people are unhappy is because,
let's talk about money and unhappiness.
Your three best friends
have a BMW and you don't.
You think it's that,
you don't realize that I loved
when all my friends had BMWs
and I had nothing.
It's just perspective, man,
what are we doing here?
Like what are you valuing?
Everybody's on defense,
all the immigration issues in the world,
nobody's taking yours.
What do you think, some
immigrant's taking your job?
You suck, like if you think that, right?
You think somebody else
is taking your spot?
This is the world, we live in the richest,
you know richness world,
in the U.K. market,
you live in the U.K.
and you're complaining?
Get the hell out of here.
So that's practical,
you have a family member or a childhood
that put you in a mindset
of defense, and listen,
I know I'm going to get
a lot of hits on Twitter
and Instagram about this
interview now when I spit this,
'cause I know a lot of
people haven't heard of me
or have context of me,
let me just say this.
The answer to everything
is, and what now, right?
Like I know people grew up
in alcoholic households,
I know people were molested,
I know people had somebody
steal all their money,
here's my problem, nobody cares.
Like, what are you waiting for?
There is no fair fairy
flying down from the earth
saying you were born an
African American in America
where that's an issue,
here's a million dollars.
That's not happening, so my
thing is, instead of dwelling,
and wishing how it was, understand,
back to the next practical
part of your question,
that the internet is now here.
And guess what, the internet's
not a 76-year-old white man.
It's the internet and that
means everybody's got a shot.
So go take yours.
It's happening on YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram,
go figure it out instead of shitting on it
and thinking it sucks,
and go get your money, happiness,
and that's it, simple as that.
I've got no time for people complaining
because it's just not true anymore.
1986, yes, 2018,
why do you think Me Too is happening now?
The internet won, it's over, go get yours.
I'm doing a pop-up store for
the K-Swiss joints tomorrow,
so it's going to be a lot of people.
- [Fan] He got us all
pairs, so thanks Gary!
- Yeah, sorry.
(laughing)
$800 on eBay, if you want to buy some!
God, I loved this song when it came out.
- [Cameraman] Spooky, bruh,
just watching your last snap.
- Timing's everything,
stay well, take care.
We haven't missed any, so what do we have?
One-on-one, so handsome, what?
- It's like it's my own Instagram account.
Hey everybody, it's pro-tip Tuesday.
We are at the Red Rooster
Restaurant and Shortage
here in London and we
are about to kick off
a round-table dinner with a
bunch of really great people.
We're just waiting for Gary to show up,
but once he gets here, this
thing is going to get going.
Lot of good conversation,
hopefully some debate,
but it's going to be exciting,
and some really good food.
I saw chicken and waffles on
the menu so let's get going.
- My favorite thing in,
like, maybe the world,
is getting together with
smart or interesting people
and being involved in one
singular conversation.
So the rule, we're going
to have a little more time
to yap a little bit, but at some point,
maybe in like 20 minutes after we order,
we're gonna go into one
conversation as a group,
you know I think you positioned it with
voice and other things,
obviously with you here,
and obviously that will come up,
but I think we should
definitely talk about,
I'm just going to level it up a hair more
which is like culture, attention,
current, this moment in time, obviously,
everybody will have
different perspectives,
but having this group
should be a lot of fun.
Thank you so much for everybody
who was able to make it,
thanks to the Vayner
team that schlepped over
from New York to be a part of this.
So why don't we do this,
why don't we start with introductions,
to give everybody context, so
who you are, where you work,
and maybe one little piece
of context about your career
or your points of view,
so why don't we start?
Yes?
(urban music)